[Musique]
les baladins d'oléron
viennent de loin parmi les champs de blé
les bonnes gens regardaient les écoutes
et les étoiles leur parle de danse et
des vieux château dressé dusong
moyen-âge semble guider leurs pas léger
comme un matin et parmi les donjons
dressé dans les nuages et princesses
l'enfant dessine avec les mains mais les
gars de 20 trains qui ressemblent à des
dieux a susurré soyeux améliorons de
folles passe sous les donjons
une part
ils ne regardent pas les bras tendus
vers ce temps ceux dont jolie pas la
leur c'est la balade c'est la ballade en
seconde je lis pas radin c'est la valeur
de table le cas ces baladins
qui serpentent les routes mais qui
sont-ils en rond dans leurs costumes
d'or des vagabonds août et dieu quand
des routes
ils n'ont que des chansons pour seul
trésor
quand ils n'auront plus soif ayant bu à
la brume
ils danseront pieds nus sur des fils
argentés que samia rennais qui seront
sous la lune d'une branche de moins
jusqu'aux sapin gelé ils sont tard quand
ben ali dans le road movie paris dans
son
on longe cheveux bouclés êtes un cortège
bleu
de mandoline où flotte un peu partout
des voix
c'est ainsi klose il le plus tôt au
mariage de l'art signe du vent avec
narre le tien mais tout cela n'était
qu'un fragile mirage et or est tout seul
avec nous
de même deux en dix mois
[Musique]
à
bt
[Musique]
non
c'est bien
[Musique]
là
j'avais
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est là
non
c'est
ca
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]